[Music]
who was going on YouTube on gamma washes
out as you can tell like this videos not
supposed to be funny it's not supposed
to be life is funny entertaining thing
but I'm here just to kind of talk and
connect with you guys because I haven't
been able to really do this in a while
and this is going to be a bit of a
serious tough so I hope you guys are
kind of strapped down and you're ready
to watch this because I need to relate
this message to you because you guys
have been supporting me since day one
number one I'm dying I'm tearing I
should be juggling my best items on the
fix what if I'm sorry listen let me just
give you a background of what's been
going on with me for like the past year
as you guys can tell I've been extremely
busy not busy in the sense of my media
saying and I'm busy like Instagram model
Pippy oh my god turn around look at my
[ __ ] off it's busy day but
legitimately busy you guys have seen
what I've been doing for the past nine
year and a half working on you know goop
the film which took up a majority of my
last year and it was an exhausting
exhausting experience but at the same
time like we got into Sunday we sold our
film we're touring it all over the place
and that film no matter how tiring it
was it was worth every every gripe and
pain that it took to get there I have
been working non-stop
like I have a saucer shop that I opened
up but I am opening actually tomorrow
May 21st and then on top of that it was
like so many other things that we're
doing thanks very much passion based and
but there's a problem in that I think
like I have this huge fear of being like
useless like I don't ever want my time
to be wasted and if I'm wasting my time
doing [ __ ] I I feel bad and I don't
really take time to rest properly and I
go take time to really sit there and
kind of care for myself because I feel
like while I'm young I'm going to work
my ass off and do everything that I need
to do but I want to do especially when
it comes to my career path I'm not
really like taking care of myself like
personally like I'm not taking care of
my personal life my personal health and
like the relationships that I should be
developing but I'm going to
to me at the end of the day when all
this disappears like those things I have
not been developing I've just been stuck
in a room trying to develop content new
ideas I'm working on this other film
that I want to put out I'm also working
on like a webseries that's going to be
on a different network I'm like trying
to sell TV shows on top of like doing
other type of film projects doing food
stuff you know trying to do this YouTube
thing at the same time and I have kind
of lost sight about the things that make
me happy I'm not miserable I'm not
depressed that's not this is not what
this video is about if you guys haven't
figured this out already or you guys
will find an out sooner or later is that
you will begin to prioritize what's
important to you as you start to get
older when I started realizing to myself
is that money and you know quote-unquote
being successful in the eyes of others
is not something that I really give too
much it's about yeah money it helps so I
don't have to be on the street you know
you know passing down hand jobs like as
crackers but the things that I care
about the most are sucking away from me
my family you know my relationship and
it's not because I'm a bad person it's
not because I don't care or love for
them it's because I'm not spending time
to develop those things like I am
developing my career the funny thing is
is like when your career ends you know
people go around the career path I
wanted to benefit from being around
you're not going to be around you when
you're nobody like that those things
don't matter but the people reduce to
karate your family your friends the
people that you love so they love you
for who you are they kind of see what's
inside here a bunch of Twinkies they
appreciate you and those are the people
I the type of relationship should be
developing and I haven't been able to do
that mainly because I'm so exhausted
I'm tired like I'm spending my love and
hardened energy the things that don't
matter as much loving yourself to you by
the way isn't just like saying hey I'm
an awesome person loving yourself is
also like being able to develop you to
spend time with yourself and better
understand yourself and when you do that
you've set a strong foundation in your
own you know your personal life that
stuff will bleed out to your personal
life that you have with other
people as well so it's kind of like when
your foundation is shaking you're trying
to build a building on top of that it
this is really [ __ ] matter the
foundation is [ __ ] and that's kind of
running out right now so basically with
this video what I'm telling you guys
that I'm going to be away from YouTube
and a lot of other things for at least
about a month to a month and a half
what does that mean for for me and you
hopefully you guys will come back to the
channel I know a lot of you guys I won
somebody's dollar for a month and I know
how like YouTube subscription feeds work
if you don't upload them a long time
they push your [ __ ] down to the bottom
and that you don't even know that I
uploaded a new video so I need you guys
to be conscious of that if you guys
really do care about the content I'm
putting out I will see you guys in the
bottom last two months and a half I'm
just going to take time for myself and
just really get that's my personal life
I will be a different person when I come
back and I just need that that time I
will be back though thank you guys so
much for always being understanding and
being supportive and when I come back in
about a month or a month and a half or
so and this is hard for me because me
not coming back for a month in a month
and a half is like me not having a
paycheck for all month like I'm not
gonna I got I got a bite that bullet I
gotta be a little bit more broke is what
it is like I'm kind of like dealt with
it like I understand so I'll be back I'm
coming back to y'all soon enough just
let me uh let me better myself and then
I'll yeah yeah if you guys don't want to
keep in contact with me you already know
what's up follow me on instagram let me
on facebook and twitter and else i'll
still be on there probably not as much
but i'll be on there you know we could
connect to that so love y'all remember
focus on the things that make you happy
and that are pretty the conducive to
where you're going to end up in life if
money is the only thing that you're
chasing i'm telling you right now from
somebody who grew up [ __ ] third poor
and even though i'm not rich it's still
the same [ __ ] you money will not make
you happy money makes you like easier
but it's not going to make you happy
when you make a certain amount of money
when you make extra after that it's not
going to change your life
people value will change how people
treat you will be different but those
people are the ones that are going to
matter stop investing your time and your
energy the [ __ ] that does not [ __ ]
matter
I know what I've done being preachy I
love y'all
[Music]
Oh
you